[♪ лунає спів ♪]
Ну, я лиш му брати.
[підіймає слухавку]
Алло!
Навіки слава Богу!
Марічко, вибачай, потому
за годинку подзвониш, добре?
Ага, але ти вибивай.
В принципі, не приймаю місто як таку пропозицію
організованого проживання людей поряд.
Село набагато органічніше,
село збалансоване.
Місто — це апріорі
порушення цього балансу.
Моя ідея тут щось робити
ще зі школи була.
Тобто я про це місце...
Завжди собі його пам'ятав,
завжди сюди з певною
регулярністю приходив.
Потім, коли вже з'явилися, власне,
якісь і час, і ресурс, то я вирішив,
що це саме цей час,
щоб тут щось почати робити.
Ну, і місце ще таким доленосним дивним
чином потрапило мені у спадок від бабусі.
То так все зійшлося.
З таким наміром щось подумати:
«Як би можна було цей простір
цікаво використовувати?»
Ми вперше сюди потрапили
2015 року у вересні.
А до того я їздив сюди, так як то,
на своє, на присадибу дивитися,
з сусідами десь заговорити...
Ми жили у Львові
і працювали у Львові.
І перші візити сюди —
на вихідні, на два-три дні.
Толокою зібралися,
зговкалися у фейсбуку:
«Хто? Що? Кому виходить?
Кому — ні?
Хто з машинами? А хто — без?».
І там збирались 10-12 людей,
і такі от заїзди.
Раз в жовтні з'їхалися,
раз в листопаді з'їхалися.
Потім на зиму забралися.
І вирішили, що нам треба
когось тут поселити.
То ми написали потім,
що «Дідова хатчина» шукає ґазду.
Ми готові надати це місце
для проживання будь-кому,
хто готовий в таких умовах жити
і заодно нам за цим простором дивитися.
І ми думали, що то
буде дуже важко знайти,
але насправді дуже багато
виявилося охочих.
Загалом було багато людей,
які свого роду таким чином волонтерили.
Вони жили тут,
дивилися за будинком.
Не сильно займались господарством,
бо люди з міста не завжди...
Ніколи...
[сміються]
Бо люди з міста і кінець.
Крапка просто.
Бо люди з міста.
Це закінчене речення.
Ну, вони ніколи не зможуть
так відповідально і настільки правильно
доглядати за господарством
тут у горах, як місцеві.
І цей якийсь певний шлях
продовжувався.
Люди змінювались.
Паралельно з ними
вже жив Микола.
Микола — це наш такий резидент
і важливий член команди,
який теж приїхав на три місяці,
залишився вже на три роки.
Коли я їхав сюди,
взагалі не розумів,
що тут буде,
ну, як воно буде відбуватись.
І приїхав, вдало, скажімо так,
наше знайомство пройшло,
бо ми не були знайомі
ні з Дариною, ні з Олегом.
Але багато спільних знайомих,
і так вийшло,
що на основі спільних друзів,
спільних якихось поглядів
та інтересів я почав сюди їздити.
Їздив раз на, умовно, кілька місяців,
потім ця частота збільшувалася,
збільшувалася і вирішив переїхати.
[розмовляють між собою]
Не хочемо взагалі в такій площині фігурувати:
якийсь готель чи зелена садиба.
Це місце, де ми [можемо]
прийняти гостей.
Я би не називав цих людей
туристами ні в якому разі.
І дати цим людям, гостям нашим, можливість
з нами потусуватися, з нами пожити.
Ми не будемо їх обслуговувати.
Я просто покажу,
де вода,
і, якщо треба буде,
можеш сходити, її принести.
Або ти можеш дров наколоти,
або підкинути сам у ватру,
або зготувати їсти,
якщо є таке бажання або необхідність.
Наш власний формат полягає в тому,
що ми впускаємо людей
в цей мій храм,
бо тут жили діди мої.
Для мене це щось більше,
це — моя церква.
І для мене це щось більше,
ніж просто плейс [місце].
Тому умови в нас
дещо такі, напевно, некласичні.
[розмовляють між собою]
Цей, правда?
Ти за цей казав?
Та типу того...
А тут можна тако рівно?
Так-так-так!
Бо воно там...
— Угу, угу. Дзюбок...
— Дзюбок такий.
— Можна й дзюбок.
І тут є сусіди, сусіди всі…
Тобто все почалось з одного вуйка.
Він тут цей горб, якби, освоїв.
І потім в нього були діти,
і він так поділив цей горб.
А ті діти ще мали
своїх дітей і ще поділили.
І дуже далекі зазвичай тут всі…
У нас четверо сусідів
довкола нашої ділянки.
То тут всі далекі родичі переважно.
А відносини з ними,
як з близькими родичами.
На жаль чи на щастя, гроші тут
абсолютно не визначальний фактор.
Тут людиною треба бути.
Треба бути відкритим і треба бути
уважним до своїх сусідів,
і так само [бути]
до них доброзичливим.
Бути напоготові стати їм в пригоді.
І це буде однозначно дзеркально.
І це величезна цінність,
якої не дуже…
Скажімо так, зі мною
особисто в місті,
на жаль, це не працювало
таким чином.
— Які тут правила?
— Правила? Ой, у нас такі класні правила.
Перше, що тут немає правил.
[сміється]
— Правила є! Як нема, ти що?
— Є, є.
Ну, по-перше, ми солідарні
з місцевими правилами.
Бо у храм зі своїми правилами не ходять,
це дуже добре треба розуміти.
Ти не можеш прийти
і тут педалитись,
що ти знаєш щось краще,
ніж ті люди, бо вони тут в селі,
що вони тут знають,
я тут прийшов «дуже знаючий».
Ні, тут люди набагато крутіші,
бо вони в балансі,
набагато більше збалансовані
внутрішньо і зовнішньо,
і вони набагато екологічніші
і природніші, і комфортніші.
Вони твердіше стоять на цій землі,
бо вони мають набагато
сильніший стержень, ніж ми.
[♪ лунає спів ♪]
Найближча вважається
Мануся до нас.
У неї дуже цікаве життя.
І вона є для мене і для нас загалом
таким одним з найбільших прикладів
відношення до життя
і природньої мудрості.
Те, що не начитано,
те, що не набачено,
а те, що вона з нею народилась.
На, Олег, Мануся тобі серп старовіцький...
Дякую, але що я з ним буду робити?
— Я даю серп в подарок!
— Я не маю, що жати.
Ще лиш молота бракує.
А дивисі, який я найшла
черевик давній з дідів!
Та, Манусю, та видів,
це й не треба нам це.
Але я найшла давнє!
Нє, нє, я не про черевик.
Я за ці видельці.
У нас є доста видельців.
Та? Йой, та в мене багато є таких,
вже й не маю, що робити.
І беріть, у вас гості
приходять, хай буде.
Та дякуємо, але ми теж будем
думати, що з цим робити.
Та що, та до вас приходять
гості, та й ви...
Та є у нас видельці вдома.
Чуєте, може ви комусь дасте,
кому більше треба?
Може, хтось прийде?
Мануся Припірська чи хто...
Ті килими — то всі ваші?
Та, та, та.
Та й то так.
Та, це все моя робота,
все я це робила, бо є робота.
Я би ші так ткала, аби мені очі так,
я би ші так ткала...
Люблю так ткати,
я прясти не дуже люблю,
а ткати так люблю, що йой!
— То це ви цю вушечку напряли?
— Так, я пряла.
Слухайте, то ви ще й рухи пам'ятаєте?
Так, [нерозбірливо],
я би зараз попряла.
[нерозбірливо]
А вони хотіли чогось гуцульського.
А я думаю,
та що я таке їм покажу?
А пані [по] що ви ходили?
Чи так собі просто подивитися?
Ті фотографували, 'ки я пряла.
Якісь фотографісти?
— Якісь дівчата від вас були.
— А, від нас хтось був?
Що було п'ятеро:
три дівчини, та й хлопець, та й...
— Я не знаю їх.
— А, все-все-все!
Вже кімую [розумію].
То я кажу...
[♪ Мануся співає ♪]
Я їм співала це та й пряла!
[сміється]
— Та й файно.
— А вони мене фотографували.
Були ідеї стосовно
фінансування цього місця.
Все-таки унезалежнити
його якимось чином,
раз це ми називаємо
соціальним проєктом,
тобто проєктом, який покликаний
нести якусь цінність громаді.
То ми вирішили, що треба паралельно
завести якусь історію,
яка би називалася, напевно,
соціально відповідальним бізнесом,
який би свої кошти перенаправляв
на підтримку, хоча би підтримку,
мінімум, скажімо, підтримку цього
місця і з його діяльністю разом.
І ми думали про то,
якою би діяльністю зайнятися,
який би такий бізнес
соціальний придумати,
який би пасував до цього, чи що.
От.
І тут була сусідка, і я якось
наважився їй запропонувати.
Ми перебуваємо в майстерні «Ґушка»,
де виготовляємо різні
вироби з вовни, все, що можна:
ліжники, пледи, килими, верхній одяг.
Хочу показати, звідки назва
нашої майстерні «Ґушка» якраз.
Ну, бо ми на великий моток напрядаємо,
потім мотаємо — робимо ґушку,
накручуємо на цей пальчик
і легенько накручуємо сюди.
Тоді цей хвостик для того,
щоби він не розкручувався, ховаємо,
цей закручуємо сюди,
і ось це і є якраз ґушка.
Ліжникарство розвивалося в Яворові,
де в кожній хаті колись ткали.
Ну, всі вміють ткати,
навіть і чоловіки, й жінки, і діти,
всі вміють, знають,
звичайно, не всі це роблять.
Ми, щоб, по-перше,
зберегти традицію і розвивати,
вже придумуємо
різні техніки,
різні складності для того,
щоби наші вироби можна було
покласти в сучасний інтер'єр.
Це — Мар'яна Кіщук,
наша ткаля також.
Ткала з маленької,
ну, переважно.
Я, наприклад, вже ткаля
в третьому поколінні.
Ткала моя бабуся,
моя мама...
Мар'яна — не знаю.
У третьому? У другому?
[сміється]
Тче якраз тепер шубку — вуню...
Зараз маємо велике бажання
збудувати своє виробництво.
Пробуємо шукати фінансування,
зараз поки промальовуємо
собі якийсь певний проєкт.
Нам би дуже хотілося
об'єднати всіх ткаль.
Олег робив збори села.
Збирали всіх ткаль села і пропонували їм
можливість працювати вдома.
І частину з них ми працевлаштували
до себе на роботу,
хто мав бажання, хто хотів,
хто хотів вчитися.
Ми розуміли, що конкурент
нам — це закордон.
Якщо на ринку праці ми приходимо,
і ми хочемо з місцевими...
Їх чимось замотивувати
з нами працювати,
ми мусимо розглядати,
хто ще дає які пропозиції,
щоб ми розуміли,
бо це ринок.
Конкуренція була
з сезонними роботами.
Бо тут роботи, в принципі,
більше й нема,
і роботодавців нема,
бо немає в регіоні ніяких
ні підприємств, ні заводів, нічого.
Є кілька, наприклад, ткаль,
яких ми врятували від поїздки
в Польщу на сезонні роботи.
І це не може не тішити,
це суперприємно.
Ми досліджували ескізи,
давні ескізи із сіл навколо Косова
і цього регіону загалом,
і при можливості ми зустрічаємося
з ткалями — зі старшими жінками.
І по можливості розпитуємо,
копаємо в бік історії ліжникарства.
Давно на ринку не було видно
саме таких кольорових ліжників,
таких давніх взірців: бузтавковий,
буковинський, такі кольорові зразки.
І зараз вони повертаються.
Ми показали приклад давніх взірців,
і ткалі зараз повертаються і починають
ткати знову ті такі старі ескізи.
Бо «Хатчина» все-таки зорієнтована
більше на події і на якийсь коворкінг,
чи платформу, яка об'єднує,
в першу чергу, людей.
[♪ лунає спів ♪]
Тут настільки багато роботи і насправді
можливостей, от тільки бери й роби.
І от, знову ж, на своєму
прикладі хотілось би показати,
що люди не завжди в тому праві,
що от є місто і тільки
воно дає можливості.
Деколи люди говорять:
«Я втечу з міста на природу
і щось там собі найду».
Я, власне, не втікав ні від чого,
я цілеспрямовано йшов і йду,
і є якісь от такі, покрокові...
Воно десь швидше здобувається,
десь воно розтягується
на більше часу.
Але, власне, прикольніше
йти до чогось, ніж втікати,
бо втікати, ну, воно якесь таке собі.
[розмовляють між собою]
Ану, Олегу, ходи,
приймай зараз роботу.
Дуже гарно! Люкс!
І ще й з хрестом!
І ще й там всередині [нерозбірливо].
[сміються]
Дуже гарно!
Ми десь для себе теж певною мірою
так транслюємо це місце, цей простір,
що це наша маленька країна
у великій Україні,
і тут буде так,
як ми хочемо,
так, як нам подобається,
так, як ми відчуваємо.
І, можливо, це колись
протранслюється на всю країну.
Треба діяти локально,
не треба цікавитися політикою.
Ну, для чого це?
Абсолютно нічого не змінить.
Треба цікавитися політикою в своєму селі
чи в своїй ОТГ цікавитися.
Та, банально, в себе в квартирі,
то дуже круто поцікавитися політикою.
Більшість людей
цікавиться тими речами,
які абсолютно
для них нічого не несуть,
і цим самим тратять свій
найцінніший ресурс — час.
Діяти треба тут, вже, зараз,
змінювати себе,
змінювати ближнього,
робити навколо себе якісь зміни
і робити ту країну самому собі.
[розмовляють між собою]
Не треба нічого робити з примусу.
Треба робити щось з натхненням тільки,
з бажанням, з якоюсь хорошою...
З любов'ю, одно слово.
І це одне-єдине правило, окрім тих,
які тут в регіоні в принципі,
ми тут перебуваємо в цьому
храмі.
А в нас, кажу, головне —
не напрягатися.
Тут все, більше нема.
— І це треба було аж сюди їхати?
— Так!
Щоб не напрягатись.
Мені так.